et pour réagir à ce mauvais gouvernement
nous sommes avec sébastien huyghe député
et l'air du nord benjamin avoir
également professeur d'histoire
adhérents de la cgt du val de marne
bonsoir à tous les deux merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france on
commence par vous sébastien huyghe vous
devez être un homme plutôt heureux ce
soir vous le sarkozyste un ancien porte
parole du temps de nicolas sarkozy c'est
plutôt un gouvernement conservateur
proche des sarkozystes avec nominé
notamment la nomination de gérard
darmana oui enfin moi je trouve que
c'est surtout un un jeu de chaises
musicales où la plupart était ministre
dans le gouvernement précédent il donc
juste changé de fonction donc on a
changé les étiquettes et puis on lâche
un jeu des chaises et puis à côté de ça
on a plutôt un casting people et donc
j'ai le sentiment plutôt qu'on va aller
vers un gouvernement qui sera un peu
dans la continuité de ce qu'a fait
emmanuel macron jusqu'à présent c'est à
dire un gouvernement de la parole où on
est surtout dans la communication plus
que dans l'action et donc je crains
qu'il n'y ait pas de changement de
braquet alors que la situation de notre
pays ils exigent
nous savons qu'à la rentrée on va avoir
un certain nombre de problèmes sociaux
un tsunami social j'allais dire parce
que on voit bien que la crise sanitaire
va entraîner une situation économique
catastrophique avec des plans sociaux
massifs avec un certain nombre
d'entreprises qui vont mettre la clé
sous la porte et on avait besoin plutôt
d'un d'un gouvernement de combat
j'allais dire pour reconquérir des
marchés remontent et l'économie faire en
sorte que notre pays passe cette
situation de crise le mieux possible et
j'ai plutôt l'impression encore une fois
qu'on va se retrouver comme par le passé
comme jusqu'à présent dans dans la
communication à tout va à tout crin
plutôt que dans l'action
alors même si le député a l'air n'est
pas satisfait ce soir cavadee en bas
ma a marre on vous imagine bouillonnant
benjamin la même si votre position dans
votre chaise et ne peuvent pas vraiment
mais j'imagine que vous n'êtes pas
vraiment satisfait de ce nouveau
gouvernement
deux constats le premier constat d'abord
c'est que quand même c'est un
remaniement qui survient après la
pandémie due qu'aux vide alors que quand
on avait écouté les grands discours d'
emmanuel macron on pouvait se dire bon
on va avoir effectivement une
gouvernement à la hauteur de cet enjeu
historique va écouter on se retrouve
avec une armée d'épervier qui ressemble
étrangement quand même à celle qu'on
connaît maintenant depuis un certain
temps donc ça veut dire que visiblement
emmanuel macron et sa révolution
copernicienne de la politique est bien
échoue lamentablement avec un déficit en
terme de 2 comment dire d'attractivité
tout simplement ça c'est le premier
constat ensuite on a quand même
effectivement parce qu'on a le sentiment
même qu'on a été racler les fonds de
tiroir et on n'a pas effectivement de
prise de guerre
donc ça veut dire clairement qu'il ya un
déficit d'attractivité puis la deuxième
chose quand moi j'ai écouté la liste là
sur les chaînes d'information je me suis
dit mais alors il est claude guéant et
brice hortefeux son ministre de quoi
parce que franchement le maquereau nisme
ressemblait de plus en plus aux sacs aux
archaïsmes
mais là on voit que ça s'accélère où se
retrouvent même avec madame bachelot qui
revient monsieur darmana monsieur le
maire monsieur castex qui était encore
jusqu'à il ya quelques jours un membre
dlr donc voilà j'ai en moi je fais
partie de ceux qui disent depuis un
certain temps que le et en même temps
n'était qu'une mascarade
j'ai dit à plusieurs reprises donc c'est
l'occasion de le redire qu emmanuel
macron c'est un peu comme le capitaine
crochet il a pas deux jambes il a une
jambe il a une jambe droite hyper musclé
hypertrophié et la jambe gauche
c'est une jambe de bois et aujourd'hui
cet homme cette mascarade du en même
temps elle apparaît aux yeux de tous
même l'éditorialiste le plus obséquieux
ne peut nier cette réalité
sébastien huyghe vous qu'est ce que vous
auriez souhaité parce que c'est vrai qu
emmanuel macron veut
tracer les contours de ce nouveau chemin
il a dit reconstruire l'économie le
social et l'environnemental le culturel
dans notre pays
qu'est ce qu'il fallait pour cela pour
créer le choc parce qu'on le sait c'est
une question d'équilibré il ya 2022 qui
se profile pour le président de la
république donc le gros problème si vous
voulez c'est qu'on s'aperçoit que le
président de la république a un vrai
problème de ressources humaines et donc
il est obligé de recycler les anciens
ministres du gouvernement sortant pour
les remettre à une autre place alors que
il y avait la nécessité comme j'ai dit à
quelques instants d'un gouvernement de
combat
non mais des personnes nouvelles avec
une ligne qui soit très claire pour
l'avenir remettre une grande majorité
des anciens ministres ça veut dire
conserver la ligne précédente qui à
l'amande a lamentablement échoué
et donc c'est vrai que la nomination de
monsieur k tech castex pardon à matignon
était un signe qui pouvait apparaître
positif en termes d'idées c'est un grand
serviteur de l'état mais la
problématique c'était comme été à
nouveau un haut fonctionnaire à matignon
est donc le sentiment que ça donne c'est
on a avant tout finalement un
gouvernement qui vit qui est fait de
hauts fonctionnaires administratifs
techniciens technocrates qui sont
finalement assez éloigné de la réalité
de ce que vivent les français au
quotidien
si on répond eric dupond moretti et vous
en pensez quoi benjamin a marre de cette
nomination de cet avocat qui selon
marine le pen est plutôt classe et
militant extrême gauche qui aimerait
bien voir disparaître le rn 1 selon la
présidente du rassemblement national
vous êtes plutôt satisfait au moins par
cette nomination alors bon conte marine
le pen dit que monsieur dupont moretti
et d'extrême gauche vous savez dans la
bouche dans la bouche des crypto
fasciste
j'ai envie de dire olivier faur pourrait
passer pour marxiste léniniste donc
c'est assez rigolo bon écoutez moi
monsieur dupont moretti est
incontestablement cas
bryant qui connaît son dossier et au
sein de la macro ni déjà c'est quelque
chose qui n'est pas évident pour tout le
monde a donc là au moins on attend on
s'accordera sur le fait que c'est
quelqu'un de brillant ce tome avocat
brillant mais donc je garde un certain
nombre de commentaires d'opposition que
je ne partage pas du tout moi je me
souviens de la défense au moment du
procès de georges tron et la manière
dont il s'est est pris aux féministes et
aux plaignantes
je la trouvais j'avais trouvé ça
scandaleux il y a des fois où ses prises
de position et en tant qu avocat me
semble courageuse et aller contre la
réaction ce n'est pas systématique
j'ai été assez mais choquée de la façon
dont ils avaient dont il avait évoqué le
parquet national financier en évoquant
alors contre lequel il avait porté
plainte et qu'il avait qualifié de tarés
bon voilà donc il ya à boire et à manger
mais je vais vous dire quand on rentre
quand on accepte peut-être par suicide
ego d'être ministre pour emmanuel macron
moi je vous le dis je ne crois pas qu'on
puisse faire quelque chose dans la
feuille de route du maquereau 10 mhz
j'ai beaucoup de mal à s'imaginer qu'on
puisse faire quelque chose de correct
savez la justice et le manque de moyen
en france la justice en france
au sein des pays de l' ocde elle souffre
d'un manque de moyens
je dirais cruel la question est de
savoir est ce que monsieur dupont
moretti va pouvoir mettre pas pouvoir
mettre sa verve au service justement de
cette grande cause qui consiste à pour
tenir des moyens budgétaires pour la
justice
s'il obtient ça sera déjà pas mal les
gens doutent j'en doute fortement
autre nomination un qui est très
commentée évidemment celle de gérald
darmanin à l'intérieur exit christophe
castaner vous êtes plutôt satisfait sur
ce point là sébastien oui il faudra
forcément mieux selon vous que ce très
très proche des manuels macron qui
finalement été mis son banc de touche
sur écoute et je pense que c'était
important que que chris que christophe
castaner sortent du goût du gouvernement
notamment après les déclarations qu'il
avait eue contre les policiers alors
qu'il est censé être le premier flic de
france
clairement il avait
vilipendé les policiers alors qu'il
fallait les soutenir nous avons les
policiers l'une des meilleures polices
au monde
c'est pas parce qu'il ya quelques
brouilles brebis galeuses qu'il fallait
jeter l'opprobre sur l'ensemble des
forces de sécurité de notre pays et donc
il est normal qu'il soit sorti du
gouvernement après j'allais dire une
série de bourdes très importante après
la la nomination de gérald darmanin
posées aux quelques questions puisque il
est sous le coup de la justice est ce
que c'était vrai il véritablement sa
place
par contre gérald darmanin c'est bon il
a un beau parcours en tant qu'élu de la
république
il habitait le ministre des comptes
publics maintenant il accède au
ministère de l'intérieur
la question va être la politique qui va
le mener qui va aller là-bas
la dernière question pour vous benjamin
a marre vous garder en tant que histoire
de profs professeur pardon et sa
géographie vous gardez votre ministre
blanca vous devez être ravi a coûté on
est ravi ah c'est la définition même de
la double peine a c'est à dire que on a
la foi tout le mal que l'on pense du
gouvernement mais par contre on conserve
ce blanc caire qui a des relations
exécrables avec les syndicats
d'enseignants qui s'est distingué quand
même rappelons le par son brio ou maman
de la pandémie on se souvient que le
jeudi matin il annonçait que les cours
se était maintenue dans les écoles et le
soir on apprenait que les écoles étaient
fermées ensuite on connaît tout
l'épisode et toute la halle toute la
saga autour de la fermeture de la
réouverture des écoles alors qu'en
italie en espagne des clusters
comparable à la france les écoles
étaient fermés jusqu'en effectivement
aider et les cours ne reprenais qu'en
septembre
donc dans le monde de l'enseignement on
est vraiment ravi de conserver monsieur
blanc caire honnêtement c'est un cadeau
c'est un c'est un magnifique cadeau de
congés scolaires
on est ravis dans les écoles à mon avis
on a dû faire je pense un certain nombre
de brasiers de joie merci jamais on
souhaite de bonnes vacances on espère
que vous avez pas partir trop énervé
merci également à vous sébastien we go